what I love about vision is what I think
he's the sort of flipside of Ultron you
know they're both born on camera which
is very odd thing for a 50 year old
actor and a 40 year old actor to do
doubt it's going to come up again and
you you know you're you're both sort of
omnipotent and was supremely powerful
and yet you're both incredibly naive and
figuring out your purpose in life and
vision very much decides that he is for
life on the side of life and Ultron goes
a very different way every year or so
I'd be asked to come into a sound booth
with a microphone talk for two hours
solve some problems everybody was happy
and then they give me a big bag of cash
and I would go home in it that sound
like it was a great contract obviously
and then suddenly I had to come in and
work for my money but if you can call it
work but but on the plus side you're
working you know actually getting to
sort of physicalize this thing and be
working with these really creative funny
and bright witty people and it was heard
they were incredibly welcoming it was a
real it was a real joy it was very happy
set as well it should be they're all
very well paid it was just really nice
on the first day to finally be on Saturn
and everybody was really welcoming and
it was a bit there's a scene in it when
I give a big speech where I'm trying to
convince them to that we all need to
join forces and work as a team and I was
just great to be there and have a big
chunk to do well it took about six
months of makeup tests flying backwards
and forwards from New York and to London
and
[Music]
the the the makeup was about a makeup
and costume is about three hour process
and about twenty furious seconds to take
off you know it's glued to your skin the
whole thing is glued to your skin down
to about here and then you go there's
really cumbersome costume on and you
really kept punching the seen it at the
end with James Spader this is just
lovely to see all that all of you know
he was in a fractal suit with these
cameras that hang off his head like that
like an insect with headlights on and
count and they're filming him the whole
time and and I'm purple and and all of
it fell away and you were just left with
this sort of father-son relationship
which I thought was a testament to what
a lovely actor is it's gonna be hard to
just keep getting bigger and better and
they've really done it and you know I've
I've never seen a movie look so big but
also it has a richness to it that I
think is unique it's really it's really
fulfilling you know it's got a it's got
real heart in the center of the story
for me the toughest day was the the the
if I was working five days in a row in
that suit the first day was fine
I mean it's uncomfortable and
claustrophobic and you can't hear in
your you only part of your entire body
that is open to the air as this and
that's covered in purple makeup first
and you can't really hear first day is
fine second day is okay third day get a
little touchy and the fourth and the
fifth day you really had to get very zen
about it he wanted me to be less knowing
and sort of experiencing the world in
real time and and to really be thinking
of things as you're speaking them as if
you'd ever thought of them before which
is which is tricky it's but it was a
really
because he's just been born and yet he's
omnipotent and yeah he has no moral
compass and he has to decide what his
purpose is in life and what he's going
to do with suddenly being and and he was
really good at keeping me on track with
with that it was great I was slack jawed
the whole way through it the whole way
through it I just never seen anything
look so large and then visions birth is
so cool
you